dirk elbers getappt und her zu einem
neuen video und sie arbeite ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut wir sitzen heute
hier auf ganz locker lässig entspannt um
meinen letzten koffer auspacken in denen
ich sehr sehr viel hoffnung steckt
eigentlich die meiste weil das war der
teuerste
es ist der schwerste es ist ein damen
koffer wer sich von euch jetzt fragt
hält was labert der typ da ich habe vor
ungefähr zwei wochen drei koffer
hersteller vielleicht hier noch mal ein
kurzer ausschnitt aus dem vorvorletzten
wie die rhythmen normalerweise gibt es
dann so alle zwei monate glaube ich von
lufthansa am frankfurter flughafen
irgendwelche koffer optionen produkt
koffer ersteigern kannst halt mit inhalt
und so sieht das denn aus drei koffer
ihr könnt ihr jetzt mal schätzen glaubt
ihr das wird sich lohnen oder nicht
genau in diesem video haben wir bereits
ein handgepäcks koffer so ein kleiner
ausgepackt acht kilo gleich und so einen
herren kopfhörer das schon elf kilo
hatte der die habe ich beide ersteigern
und jetzt kommt noch hinzu dieser fette
damen kupfer ist wirklich eine sehr
große kommen habe ich zeit mich mal
wobei ich meine er wäre auch schon in
dem wieder mal drin gewesen so sieht er
aus schwimm pink also ja gut so richtig
knallig pink ist das jetzt auch nicht
aber ich bin mir sehr sicher dass das
hier einen daran koffer ist wirken muss
ich leider sagen dass die ersten beiden
körper jetzt nicht so das gelbe vom ei
war also da war halt sehr sehr viele
anziehsachen grint mehr auch nicht
zumindest nichts womit man jetzt
unbedingt was anfangen kann oder was man
teuer verkaufen kann
das liegt eventuell auch daran weil es
schon hin und wieder vorkommt oder was
heißt hier nun wieder ich glaube das ist
standard so haben auch viele von euch in
die kommentare
das bekommen wir vorher einmal
durchleuchtet werden und viele sachen
die er wirklich rauer sind entnommen
werden was ein bisschen weg ist weswegen
ich auf jeden fall sagen kann für alle
die sich für koffer option interessieren
kauft keinen koffer für 30 oder sich
einfach nicht ich habe diesen jahres für
350 euro ersteigert und ja ich bin
gespannt bei den letzten beiden koffern
hat sich halt nicht gelohnt ob sich
jetzt wirklich zeigt wir haben
das riecht schon wieder ganz gut ich
erinnere mich noch gut an den koffer von
der schwedin der wunderbare durfte
wobei was man auch sagen muss die koffer
an sich kostet ja auch schon gern mal
100 euro ich meine wir haben große lust
den koffer allein mit dieser koffer
kostet zum beispiel hier auf der seite
104 euro 95
schade es jetzt gebraucht und es
wahrscheinlich nicht mal mehr die hälfte
wert aber hat auch mal was gekostet
sodann habe ich jetzt genug gelagert
staaten immer rein wir haben hier ein
podcast oder kannst du drauf hast kannst
du deine hand zu legen dann wird dir war
das müssen wir auf jeden fall wieder
rausfinden oder vermutungen aufstellen
wo dieser koffer herkommt aus welchem
land raum an wobei wir es offensichtlich
eigentlich frau weiter geht's es kommt
so wieder so leicht erfreut ich mir auf
weil herrlich macht es auch spaß muss
auspacken
wir haben wir eine wunderbare nacken die
ist von tschechiens industrie am penis
sagt mir gar nichts die marke sofort den
preis mal nach und welche euch hier ein
hat auf jeden fall glaube ich gute
qualität und wenn ich diese jacke so
sehe gehe ich mal davon aus dass der
koffer auf einer weiblichen person
gehört die auf jeden fall über 30 ist
oder vielleicht sogar über 40 dann haben
wir hier dieses wunderbare oberteil
hey da würde ich da gar nicht mit
rumlaufen das ist in größe m
die herren hatten die jacke ist in größe
l ok also auf jeden fall keine kleine
person
hier ist sogar noch ein preisschild
vielleicht war sie im urlaub unterwegs
hat sich das den ort vor ort gekauft das
ist von tools und hat 35 eur 99 gekostet
da war sie wahrscheinlich im urlaub
richtig stickstoff hat sich gefreut bei
ihren freunden zu hause wieder die neuen
sachen anzuziehen und dann hat es
einfach in den koffer verloren
blöd gelaufen ich scheiße so weiter geht
es mit einer leggins ebenfalls frisch
erworben für vier euro
ihnen ist es auch ein bisschen komisch
nicht mein würdet ihr in urlaub fahren
okay vielleicht war sie auch nicht man
weiß es nicht aber ich persönlich kann
ich in urlaub geht an das shoppen und
kaufen wir irgendwas für 49 90 so das
kann ich auch in meiner heimatstadt
machen weiter geht's mit
wir haben die creme ungeöffnet oder raus
da war sie noch nicht dran
stell dich mal hier neben dann haben wir
hier passiert
guck mal das ist auf französisch
deswegen können wir davon ausgehen dass
dieser koffer einer französin gehörte
gehört jetzt nicht welches meiner
adresse da sage ich nicht gerade leicht
also ja man rasiert sich auch als frauen
weitergeht ich glaube jetzt abercrombie
nehmen ist das denn hier auch immer dass
es auch gerade erst gekauft ebenfalls
dies irgend großer fan von der marke
james 29 eur 99 auch noch das
preisschild dran dann haben wir hier
noch mal so ein ding hier sind ja
eigentlich nur neue sachen drin echt
irgendwie ein bisschen komisch hier
haben wir nochmal so krämer dann noch
alles ungeöffnet ich würde mir jetzt
vermuten das war wahrscheinlich einen
koffer für den hin weg für den urlaub
kaufen ja auch manche leute ganz neue
lena ticket aber wieso man das schild
hier dran selbst bei den ganzen sachen
auf einmal hier 39 99 auch komplett neu
das verstehe ich nicht
dann 28 eur 99 ja das sieht jetzt auch
also mittlerweile sieht das schon echt
alles der französisch aus ihr diese zu
bisschen bargeld essen damit morgens
weiter geht's hier mit ihr haben wir
sowas wie feuchttücher oder auch auf
französisch links netto land ist multi
user es ist ganz ganz wichtig gut dass
sich drei jahren von sie sich in der
schule hat deswegen kann ich das jetzt
natürlich alles verstehen nein ich habe
alles vergessen
dann haben wir noch mit creme hier
irgendwie körper milch also wegen
milch meine zumindest mixa intensiv
perfekt so also auf der rechten seite
war eigentlich na ja nicht nur quatsch
die ganzen sachen haben bestimmt jetzt
einen gesamtwert von über 150 euro aber
jetzt nix geile zeit
dann machen wir mal erst mal hier oben
die tasche auf wobei hier ist glaube ich
nichts mehr sehen und kommen dann wird
das hier oben ist ja erfahrungsgemäß
immer der teil mit viel oder mit
besseren sachen karriere schuhe an und
folie die ja ich ja gar nichts mehr
wieso nimmt man den folien in seinem
koffer mit ok hier starten wir mit neuen
socken hat es ja auch extra noch
gekauften urlaub die hatte ja eigentlich
nur neue sachen in ihrem koffer weiter
geht's mit diesem hemd ebenfalls nicht
kommen erst jetzt zum beispiel mal kein
preisschild dran von seo dann haben wir
hier eine weitere leggins ebenfalls wird
für 199 dann haben wir hier alufolie die
kann ich selber gut gebrauchen jährige
nach hause aber ich habe keine mehr
das ist wirklich das erste teil aus
einkäufern wo ich sagen okay da kann ich
persönlich etwas anfangen und auch mehr
alu folie so dann haben wir hier die
neuen erfroren oder auch da steht ja gar
keine marke trotzdem ist das wünschen
sie hatte auf jeden fall schon
240 10 mal kurz an und präsentieren euch
also ich habe schon größe 43 aber ein 42
auch noch einen so gerade kann man auf
jeden fall wollten das ding
okay dann haben wir hier noch die nähte
warum hat die denn knete dabei ja okay
vielleicht hat sie eine freundin besucht
die hat kinder und das war ein geschenk
für die kinder ihr bekommt heute von mir
knete oder auch auf französisch bonjour
schied wie amelia stetig q2b songs die
kinder
okay dann haben wir hier noch
sie lag dort bereit mehr wie
entschuldigung e mail zitiert 6322 oder
wer meine alte aber ich hoffe die schau
dieses video richtig 1 gewann der club
das hier was ist das denn
ja da setzt sich hat so also vielleicht
kassieren wert auf das recht auf jeden
fall gut hier haben wir das ist sonja
fuss sind so thöle für die haut glaube
ich ne oder irgendwelche dürfte das weiß
ich gar nicht genau bei kostet sowas 20
30 euro und zu guter letzt haben wir
dann auch einen pokal
also auf diesen koffer hat kann ich
wirklich gar nicht so kleinen mini
hocker fürs badezimmer kannst du dich
drauf stellen dann kannst du auch als
kleiner mensch im spiegel gucken
vielleicht auch für die kinder leser und
form und leider war es das auch
okay leute koffer ist leer wir haben
jetzt mal wieder aber wie erwartet auch
keine allzu große ausbeute gemacht viele
klamotten viel neues zeug warum das in
diesem koffer land keinen plan es ist
mal wieder keinen kulturbeutel drin was
halt ein bisschen komisch ist und ich
weiß nicht in dem koffer war doch so
viel platz der war gar nicht richtig
ausgefüllt dieses dinge zum beispiel
liegt allein schon 238 mehr drei kilo
deswegen 14 kilo dann halt auch schnell
erreicht sind
also ich habe mir wirklich viel viel
mehr erhofft von dem koffer videos ich
höre mich auf jeden fall mega freuen
wenn ihr alle den kanal abonniert ist
kommen in zukunft sehr sehr gute sachen
auch wenn ihr weitere ideen habt für
unboxing oder sachen die ich bestellte
schreibe es in die kommentare
live kommentare die euch gefallen mit
guten ideen das hilft mir auf jeden fall
immer sehr und die ganzen sachen könnt
ihr in meinem shop kaufen lucky bonn.de
ich mache glaube ich drei oder vier
pakete ich dann halt zufällig sachen
rein waller und auch die koffer also
dein körper braucht check dass man leute
danke dass du schon dann noch umgebaut
rein das was von mir bis sonntag